good afternoon everybody so last time
last time I asked who had been immunized
so does anyone know if they've taken
antivirals Tamiflu acyclovir see much
fewer people then immunized which is
good that's the way it should be you
should only take an antiviral if you're
infected and you haven't had a vaccine
so that's all we're going to talk about
today antivirals and as we said last
time vaccines have been pretty
successful in preventing viral diseases
but if you're already infected they
usually don't have much of an in fact of
an effect right
what is the one exception you can be
infected and still be immunized
vaccinated did somebody say rabies yes
yes because the incubation time is so
long for rabies that even after you're
bitten there is time to get the vaccine
and to develop immunity that will
protect you from dying because rabies is
about a hundred percent fatal because
the virus takes a long time to travel up
nerves but for all the other cases when
you're already infected you need an
antiviral so that's what we're gonna
talk about today that's our second
arsenal antiviral drugs they can stop an
infection once it has started now we've
been working on antivirals for about 50
years I only have about 30 and part of
the talk today we're going to explore
why that's so and most of these are
against HIV and herpes viruses these of
course not unco incidentally turn out to
be chronic infections they go on for
long periods of time so you can diagnose
them and treat as opposed to an acute
infection which is over in a few days so
here are some examples of the some of
the antivirals we have not all of them
these are some target
here you can see there are targets that
many of the steps of the replication
cycle uncoding replication preliminary
DNA polymerases and reverse
transcriptase is processing and virus
release so we'll talk about some of
these in some detail today and you can
see mostly HIV herpes viruses influenza
we have three antivirals against flu and
coming up now are a number of hepatitis
C virus antivirals brand new ones just
in clinical trials about to be used
we'll talk about those as well so why
are there sooo so few antiviral drugs
one of the reasons is that you know
viruses are obligate parasites of the
cell so compound that interferes with
the growth of a virus may affect the
cell so you can have the right effects
often and we don't want to have a lot of
side effects obviously we want to
minimize them and know antiviral is
without side effects though so if you
can find a specific virus function that
doesn't exist in the cell that's a good
target
but there often is an overlap just a
random overlap with a cellular function
so you have side effects so that's one
reason most of the compounds that are
effective at inhibiting virus
replication are toxic the other reason
is many of the important viruses are
either very dangerous or we can't grow
them or we can't test them in animals so
for example HBV no one still no one can
grow hepatitis B virus in a laboratory
human papilloma viruses now can be
propagated it's not easy though rather
difficult system for many diseases there
are no animal models HIV smallpox
measles and these viruses are very
dangerous to work with Ebola lass
smallpox yes
why can't you grow it I don't know if we
knew we would grow it right people have
been struggling for years for Hep C for
example from its discovery in the 80s
no one could grow it and then so maybe
people made full-length DNA clones of
the RNA genome they put those in cells
couldn't get it to grow and then the
Japanese investigator found a different
sera type and that grew so it was just a
different sequence was able to grow so
now everyone is working with that sera
type now with h HPV required a
specialized cell culture system which
was then developed and you can now grow
those but HBV still no one can grow and
we don't know why we don't know what the
block is so that makes it hard but with
recombinant DNA the ability to express a
single protein and look for inhibitors
of its function you can still develop
antivirals but they're hard to test if
you can't grow the virus in cell culture
the first test is you're gonna see to
see if your compound inhibits growth in
cell culture so that you have to bypass
that it's very difficult third reason is
that any antiviral really must block
viral replication completely so we say
it has to be potent you can't have any
room here for replication now many of
the standard drugs that we take not for
viruses or not bet not antibiotics but
just drugs to treat various things they
work even if they partially block enzyme
activity okay but for an antiviral drug
you can't have partial inhibition
because you will get resistance if you
do that so these are very different from
most pharmaceuticals in that you require
a complete inhibition of virus
replication so they have to be safe then
you can't have side effects and they
must be potent so that's a difficult
combination and that's one of the
reasons why we have so few to achieve
both you have to do a lot of searching
and chemistry and testing and it takes a
lot of time and it's expensive and as I
said if a drug doesn't block replication
completely we will get virus mutants
in fact this is the perfect way to get
drug-resistant mutants is to have virus
replication in the presence of an
inhibitor even low levels of replication
because you will get viral mutants and
among those will be some that are
resistant and they will grow and they
will dominate the culture if you'd have
any replication you can't get resistant
mutants because there's no replication
at all so you can have no selection so
this is a theoretical graph that just
illustrates this idea we have viral load
here on the y axis with time so we have
a virus infection and we're looking at
the amount of virus we give a drug at a
certain time so in this system we start
out with high virus levels we give drug
and we wait and we measure virus over
time and the optimal dose of drug
inhibits virus replication so there's no
more maintenance of virus right here
optimal dose now load those slightly
inhibits but eventually the virus
rebounds because the resistant mutants
emerge same with even an intermediate
dose alright so again you can't have
this middle-of-the-road inhibition you
have to completely inhibit and again
that's different from a lot of other
targets for it for drugs that we take
non viral inhibitors but you don't have
to have complete inhibition to have a
therapeutic effect yes
right so when viruses replicate they
make mutants always and so if you allow
little viral replications in the
presence of a drug among the mutants of
the mate or are going to be some that
are resistant to the drug and then those
will replicate and take over right so
you want no replication zero all right
so the problem of acute infections that
most most virus infections are too short
by the time you feel ill like in a
common cold it's too late to have an
impact on the progress of the disease
okay so you have to give antivirals for
these kinds of infections very early and
influenza is a good example you have to
take an antiviral for flu within 48
hours of feeling your first symptoms
otherwise it's not going to really
affect the course of infection now an
alternative is to give drug to everybody
all the time right it's not a good idea
what why isn't that a good idea yeah
then if there's a little bit of virus
around you're going to select for
mutants and that's really bad plus you
don't want to give people drugs if
they're healthy in general right because
they can't have side effects and the
more people you give a drug the more
likely you're going to see a side effect
so you don't want to give drugs to
healthy people if we had broad-spectrum
antivirals this problem might be solved
because as soon as you feel ill you take
the broad spectrum you don't have to
diagnose what virus it is and get a
virus specific antiviral right but we
don't have any such things there's one
hint of a broad spectrum against
envelope viruses but that's far from
being developed so right now we have
antivirals that are really specific for
each virus so you have to know what you
have before you can be treated and it
takes time to identify the virus so you
feel ill maybe you wait a day until you
feel worse right and then you may go to
a physician most of us don't and then
you have to get a prescription then you
have to go to a drugstore and get it and
this by the time you do all that unless
you're very efficient some people are
if your it's gonna be too late so this
there has to be some intervention here
and really the key which I have
mentioned before is the lack of rapid
diagnostic reagents we could make
antivirals basically for any virus
that's around but if you can't use them
because of these acute issues then
they're not going to be made and
companies won't invest the money in them
until we get rapid Diagnostics so one
day we will have a rapid diagnostic
that's very accurate right now we have
some rapid ones for flu but they're 50
percent wrong half the time they're
wrong so might as well just take the
antiviral when you feel bad with flu and
as I said before that's the strategy
that's taken but someday we'll have
better ones and then you will see many
more antivirals against acute infections
so let's go and look back at the history
of antiviral drugs
the first searches really began in the
early 50s by this time there were
already a number of antibiotics used for
bacteria so people thought well we have
these drugs that block bacterial
infections we should be able to do the
same thing for viruses and some of the
early antibiotics were sulfonamide so
chemists began to modify these and check
the derivatives to see if they would
inhibit viruses then parks viruses were
large targets back then because after
we're still after World War two smallpox
was a big problem in fact as recently as
1967 millions of people died of smallpox
globally so there was still a need for
antivirals against smallpox and these
are the thio semi karbas ohms which are
found to be active in the 60s and 70s
this got momentum this whole idea of
looking for antiviral drugs they drug
companies launched what we call blind
screening programs to find chemicals
that were antiviral and again this was
spurred on by successes in treating
bacterial infections you know in the
1960s I think it was the Surgeon General
who said the end of bacterial infections
is here we have antibiotics and we don't
have to worry about them anymore
since 1960s now of course we have genes
that make you resistant to all
antibiotics the New Delhi
metalloproteinase makes all bacteria
resistant to most of the antibiotics we
have it's pretty scary so anyway that
spurred on anti viral blind screens and
what is a blind screen you don't focus
on a particular virus but rather you
just test random chemicals or natural
products for the ability to block
replication of a bunch of viruses in
cell culture natural products or you go
out and you get some dirt from the woods
and you look for something in it
produced by a microorganism that will
inhibit your particular virus companies
still do this in fact it's a very
profitable way to get antivirals because
there are many many microorganisms out
there so when you do these blind screens
you get what are called hits something
that inhibits your virus compounds or
mixtures that block your replication in
culture that you then try and purify the
active ingredient and if you're lucky
you can synthesize it you test it in
various cell cultures and animal models
and then if you get leads from these
kinds of assays you then modify them by
the chemists so the cameras to identify
what the compounds are and then they
modify them to reduce toxicity to make
them more soluble make them bioavailable
so that when you take them they they go
where they're supposed to and also to
improve their pharmacokinetic properties
you want them to last as long as
possible
between doses so you can make chemical
modifications that change all these
properties so these kinds of blind
screens went through thousands and
thousands of molecules before you even
test something in humans so you start
with a hit you make leads from it you
modify them you make thousands of
modifications in the chemistry lab and
then finally you find one which you
think might be safe you go into animal
tests and eventually into humans despite
all of this from these blind screens
very little resulted now one of the
exceptions is called a Symetra this is
the trade name for it at the chemical
name is amantadine this was approved
late-1960s to treat influenza A viruses
and we still use it in certain
situations most strains are resistant
but in some cases there is
susceptibility so it's still useful
we'll talk about the mechanism of that
in a moment but we didn't know what the
mechanism was in the 60s when this was
actually approved by the FDA we didn't
know the mechanism of inhibition we just
knew that it worked now we do know the
mechanisms for most of the antivirals
because as you'll see they're discovered
in a way that makes you understand what
the mechanism is so these the mechanisms
of amantadine inhibition was learned in
the 90s today it's very different we use
recombinant DNA technology to identify
specific genes whose gene products can
be inhibited we use very sophisticated
chemistry to modify molecules in any way
that you want we have a large database
of knowing what kinds of modifications
can be made to improve this how long a
drug lasts in you and so forth so you
can do very targeted discovery and we
can clone genes as I say we can express
them we can purify them we can
crystallize them we can see where they
interact with their normal substrates
and try and design inhibitors as you've
learned from this course we know all the
life cycles pretty well so we can we can
isolate a specific phase of the life
cycle and say we want to make an
inhibitor here what are the enzymes
involved what are the viral enzymes that
are involved and so again even for those
viruses that you can't grow you can get
inhibitors you can identify an enzyme a
protease a nucleic acid enzyme and look
for inhibitors of it simply by cloning
the gene and looking for inhibitors in
cell culture so no more blind screening
procedures you have a specific virus in
mind and you have a specific target just
as an example a few weeks ago I called a
large drug company because we wanted to
write a grant to look for antivirals
against dengue which is a big problem
right and this person that I reached the
head of outside interactions said oh we
only work on Hep C and HIV
now they're very focused they don't want
to go beyond their focus no more blind
screening so if you look at a typical
replication cycle it gives you all of
the possible targets you have the virus
itself you have attachment and entry
translation replication genome
replication in particular and packaging
and release
we do have inhibitors for many of these
steps that we'll talk a little bit about
they're fusion inhibitors for HIV
there's a flu entry inhibitor interferon
is a general inhibitor of translation
but it's really not a great drug that a
lot of side effects it's used mainly for
Hep C there are various inhibitors of
nucleic acid replication for HIV and
herpes and there are even inhibitors of
virus release so we'll talk about some
examples of each of these but before we
do that just give you an idea of what it
takes to discover a drug this is the
typical pathway to drug discovery first
you say is the virus medically important
okay because if it's not you don't want
to spend money on it so you identify a
medical need you do some research to
figure out what parts of the virus you
would like to target you so you identify
a mechanism so let's say you want to
interfere with nucleic acid synthesis
it's a good bet because the viral
enzymes are virus specific you have to
do a proof of principle you have to
somehow show that that gene is essential
and typically what's done nowadays is to
delete the gene from the virus and show
that the virus doesn't replicate because
it could be that if you delete it and it
does replicate you could spend years and
years and antiviral research on that
target and it would be a waste so then
you start looking for inhibitors you
pick a target and you look for
inhibitors and again you the sources of
these inhibitors natural product
libraries every company has a big
collection of compounds they've
accumulated over the years you can make
new compounds you can now buy libraries
there are companies whose job is simply
to furnish libraries of chemicals for
various types of screens and you go
through a variety of screens and we'll
talk about mechanism based and high
throughput screens you get some hits you
then take those and
from them develop lead compounds which
you can then modify the chemists will
modify that eventually you can test them
in animals and look at toxicity
pharmacology metabolism pharmacokinetics
and that is all related to
bioavailability is the drug going to be
where it's needed to inhibit virus
replication once you're convinced that
this is a good candidate you can go into
preclinical development phase one two
and three trials in humans and
eventually if everything works out you
can get it approved by the FDA but you
cannot take dozens and dozens of
candidates down this route this is very
expensive so you have to make decisions
about which ones to go with and which
ones to cancel very tough things so this
process that we've talked about doesn't
actually find drugs a drug is a compound
that's licensed okay so the end result
in this pathway a drug is what happens
after you do all of this so this path of
drug discovery doesn't find a drug until
the very end it get hits you get leads
and you have to find a drug in the end
out of all of that some of the things
you need to answer in this process will
to get to the right place
bioavailability will it persist long
enough pharmacokinetics and will it be
safe toxicity and specificity so only
until you've answered all the questions
do you have a drug that you can test in
people so we call this research and
development for a reason because you do
research to find a lead compound and
then you have to develop it further
develop it so it's active potent not
toxic and so forth and all of this can
be one to two hundred million dollars
per drug that you're testing so that's
why you can't do ten drugs at a time so
if you're the director of antiviral
research you have to make a decision at
some point along that discovery process
a person who used to work in the
industry once told me those managers who
can't project usually lasted longer in
the company than those who let projects
go on longer because you can't a project
you save money even if you don't get a
drug in the end you don't waste money
it's a little bit ironic but that's the
way it is
so you go through thousands of leads in
the end you get one candidate for
further development and remember you
have to not only develop development is
all the steps in taking the lead
compound through safety testing which is
where a lot of drugs fail scale-up of
synthesis so you could have a very nice
candidate which looks good in animals
then you go to scale it up and you can't
do the chemistry so it fails their
formulation how you mix it with other
things to be taken as a pill or as an
injection pharmacokinetic studies and
then of course clinical trial is the
true test whether it helps people and
whether it's not toxic in people these
are the most expensive of course because
they can involve hundreds and hundreds
of people five to ten years typically
after you get that initial lead that is
the first sense that a compound is going
to inhibit your target until you get a
drug now for HIV this was fast-tracked
because it was an urgent medical need so
this was cut in half really and some
drugs were out there at a couple of
years but for most drugs it takes a long
time and a lot of money so here is the
ladder of drug discovery and we start
with hundreds of thousands of compounds
in your library and you do some screens
and you reject the bunch because they
don't have any antiviral effect in cell
culture so the red is rejected and then
you reject more because they're toxic in
cells
if the toxic in cells forget it you
don't even go further than that then you
put them in animals see if they have an
antiviral effect and then bunch don't
you reject those toxicity and animals
you reject those then you go into people
and you reject them if they don't have
antiviral effects but in fact here we're
not really testing ten compounds we're
testing one so it's either yes or no at
this point if it's if it has an
antiviral effect and it's it doesn't
have toxicity in fact you would check
the toxicity first and then the
antiviral activity in humans and then at
the end you have one compound after five
or ten years so if you want to have a
career in drug companies this is what
you're looking at you can spend five and
ten years working on a project
can you imagine then the FDA doesn't
approve it what that would do to your
self-esteem so you go to an you go
another company because you can't stand
to see all the people you work with all
those years so what here are some
examples of screens that are done this
is a mechanism based screen we're
looking for an inhibitor of a viral
protease so we know what the cleavage
site is we know what the Proteas we have
to all the research to identify that so
here's our protease we've clone it and
we can express it in some kind of system
and we develop a assay that's really
quick and can be done on high scale we
have a bead attached to a short peptide
that contains the cleavage site for the
protease and then we have a little green
light here which we can a say a green
fluorescent protein or something like
that and if the protease cleaves it will
separate the bead part from the soluble
part which has the green light on it and
you can do an essay you can go time
versus fluorescence intensity and so you
can separate you could look at the
supernatant and separate that from the
bottom part here and then if you have
inhibitors you can screen the inhibitors
of the protease because this now will be
this line will be depressed if an
inhibitor is present so you measure this
the color and the supernatant and then
that's the way you can screen for an
inhibitor here's another example of a
screen just that previous one was in
solution there were no whole cells this
is a cell based screen where you take
bacteria and you have you make them
tetracycline resistant for example by
putting a tetracycline efflux protein
into their membrane so now when you add
tetracycline they won't the the bacteria
will replicate because they have this
resistance pump that gets rid of the
tetracycline you can engineer a protease
cleavage site for the HIV protease here
this is in fact one of the screens that
was done so now if you add protease to
these bacteria you can express it in
them will cleave this part here and it
renders this a flux protein inactive so
now the bacteria are sensitive to
tetracycline so if you put in if you
screen for inhibitors of the protease
those will make the bacteria
tetracycline resistance so that will be
your readout Tetrick growth in the
presence
a tetracycline for inhibitors that block
the HIV protease so that's a cell based
screen here's another one for a viral e
this was just developed in the last
couple of years
this is for Hendra virus which is a
particularly lethal paramyxovirus it is
it is active mainly in Southeast Asia
and it's it comes from bats and infects
people it hasn't gone from person to
person yet but it's extremely lethal and
one of the main ways that people get it
in Pakistan here's a Pakistan or
Bangladesh people collect date palm sap
and they put it in these big containers
and they leave it outside their house
and at night the bats come to drink the
date palm sap because they like it and
they defecate and urinate in it and they
put virus in it the bats have this virus
they're fine and then people drink the
sap and they get they get this infection
so we're looking for antivirals but
these viruses are very dangerous to work
with you don't want to be screening
antivirals so this was an essay actually
developed at Cornell Medical College
here in the city what you do is you make
a virus you can you make a pseudo type
virus you have say vesicular stomatitis
virus which is easy to work with and
safe and you engineer the glycoproteins
of of Hendra virus into it so that it's
not dangerous as Hendra would be but you
have the glycoproteins and now you can
infect cells and look for inhibitors of
say entry because now this is Hendra
glycoproteins interacting with the
Hendra receptor on the cell surface but
that only gives you one part of the
replication cycle just the entry step
because once these once the genome gets
in the particles that produce don't have
glycoproteins because you've actually
deleted the glycoproteins from the viral
gene from the vsv genome here these
particles are made in another cell that
expresses the viral glycoprotein but the
genes for them are not transmitted what
they've done here is they express the
Hendra glycoproteins on the target cell
so now not only can this pseudo type
virus in fact but the particles that are
released will have Hendra glycoproteins
on them they still have the genome of
VSV but they can you can look at the
whole
located cycle you can look at not only
entry but budding from the host cell you
can get multi cycle infection and you
could look for inhibitors of a broader
range of targets so that's this is being
used now to look for inhibitors because
Hendra is a longer acute infection so if
you diagnose it you could apply the an
antiviral to save these people's lives
now high-throughput screening is a big
part of drug discovery you use
mechanized approaches to do this so you
use multi-well plate so your many of you
many of you may be familiar with six
well plates for growing cells in or even
96-well plates where this has 1,400
wells they're very small and each and
each well you can do an essay for a
different compound and you you don't
have people putting compounds into these
wells it's too tedious and they would
make mistakes so you have these robots
you have rooms that companies full of
these robotic arms and what they're
doing here is they're picking out the
plates from an incubator and they're
gonna place them on a table and then
another robot will inject all the
compounds into this and the arm will
take it and put it back so this is now
how it's done by these robots
high-throughput screening so by this
approach you can do ten thousand
compounds a day easily you can rip
through libraries very quickly and you
use chemical libraries as I've said that
the company may have or you could
purchase them natural products you go
out I know that Merck used to have a
whole division of people that would go
out on a daily basis and go to the
swamps of New Jersey or the woods and
just pick up samples and bring them back
and they would search them for active
compounds you can use chemistry to make
thousands and thousands of variations on
a compound if you have the structure of
your viral target you can see where the
natural ligand binds and design
inhibitors that fit in there we'll talk
about an example of that and now you can
even do in silico screening you use a
computer to say what kind of compound
will fit into this pocket the best and
you use the computer to iterate through
many many different kinds of structures
and will tell you in general what kind
of structure you need then you can
synthesize it and test it so that's
called in silico screening now when we
make all these drugs in the end
were frustrated because we get
resistance and basically any antiviral
you make you're going to get resistance
too you should not say if you're gonna
get resistance but when because that's
because viruses replicate very well they
have pretty good mutation frequencies
and we'll talk about that next time
anywhere from modest to high mutation
frequencies depending on the virus and
this is a particular concern for viruses
that replicate over long periods of time
it's paradoxical because these are the
viruses that are best treated with
antivirals you can diagnose them and you
have a long period of time for treatment
yet because they're replicating so long
they are very likely to give off
resistant mutants
we have mutants resistant to every drug
in our antiviral Arsenal right now so we
have as I said about 30 or so antivirals
and their virus is resistant to every
one of them so they in fact as you will
see doesn't matter how many we make in
the future there will always be
resistance to all of them so you really
have to have very special approaches to
get around this problem so right now the
antiviral Arsenal is small this has been
overcome as you'll see for HIV but we
haven't done that for other viruses and
infections now what's the problem with
drug resistance this is really obvious
you can't keep treating with the same
drug if a patient develops resistance to
it it's useless sometimes no other drug
is available so it's a death sentence
for the patient we do study resistance
to understand how viruses become
resistant so we would like to know the
sequences that are involved and maybe we
can get insight into getting around it
and maybe developing new strategies to
get around the problem what are the
mechanisms well RNA viruses all nucleic
acid polymerases as you know are
error-prone but those of RNA viruses are
particularly because there's no
correction mechanism they can't correct
the mistake they make and they typically
make one missing corporation for every
10,000 to 100,000 nucleotides that are
polymerized so remember the RNA viruses
have
to replicate their genomes and that's
the error rate it's about a million
times greater than the error rate of our
DNA polymerases so that's that's quite
high so in an RNA virus genome of ten
kilobases this range basically gives you
one mutation in each genome or every 10
genomes depending on the frequency yeah
so why is there any replication at all
so if you it depends if you start
treating a person they have a very large
viral load the likelihood is that
they're already resistant mutants in
there it's just one scenario the other
scenarios that people stop taking their
antivirals and you give the virus as a
window to replicate so a DNA virus is
the polymerase can excise and replace
the mistakes that are Mis incorporated
nucleotides these therefore evolve more
slowly so here is a DNA polymerase
copying a template here's the three
prime end of the growing strand you have
a miss incorporation here as soon as a
mismatch the wrong base was put in that
happens but these DNA polymerases have 3
to 5 prime exonuclease activities which
can excise the mistake and replace it so
this makes the error frequency for DNA
viruses much lower it's not non-existent
and that's probably a evolutionary
advantage you should probably make some
errors otherwise you don't evolve right
if you were totally genetically stable
you couldn't have any variation you
wouldn't be able to adapt so there has
to be some mutation rate but this is why
it's much lower for the DNA viruses so
let's talk about one drug in terms of
how it works and resistance to it
now many antivirals are used to inhibit
nucleic acid polymerases and many of
these compounds are nucleoside and
nucleotide analogs so here in the middle
you have adenosine guanosine site to
Dean and thymidine the four bases that
are used to nucleotides that are made to
build DNA and chemists have made
derivatives of each of these that are
inhibitors and you can see all these
compounds around the periphery ribavirin
AZT trifler Adeem these are all
derivatives of the four nucleotides that
are inhibitory for DNA polymerization
we're going to talk a little bit about
acyclovir which you can see is a
derivative of guanosine you can see how
it's different
it has the base same base but the sugar
is incomplete
okay and this is highly inhibitory it's
a very effective antiviral the way it
works it's used for herpes viruses this
compound in order to be incorporated
into DNA that's how it inhibits it has
to be phosphorylated and in it is only
phosphorylated by an enzyme produced by
herpes simplex virus the thymidine
kinase or the TK gene so this is very
specific for virus infected cells the
phosphorylation won't occur this first
far away phosphorylation doesn't occur
in uninfected cells so you have the
first phosphorylation event here the P
is added by HSV TK so the drug gets into
the cell if it's infected with herpes
simplex virus it gets one phosphate then
another then two other cellular kinase
has add one in two more phosphates so
now it's a triphosphate and you need
triphosphates to be incorporated into
DNA of course now this gets incorporated
into DNA alright so now we're putting in
the acyclovir right here but the problem
is that you're missing the bottom part
of the sugar right which is where the
next base would be attached so remember
if this were guanosine the hydroxyl
would be the next site of the next
triphosphate addition but there's no
guanosine here so the chain
incorporation stops so that's why this
inhibits DNA synthesis because it's a
chain terminator we call it okay we get
readily resistance to a cycle via these
mutants arise spontaneously during virus
replication and there's some kinds of
mutants that cannot phosphorylate the
prodrug these are mutations in the gene
for the viral thymidine kinase so they
don't recognize the acyclovir they can't
phosphorylate so it cannot inhibit viral
replication so these are variants of the
TK gene that are selected for by the
drug other mutants can't incorporate the
the phosphorylated drug so these mutants
they the drug is phosphorylated but
there are mutations in the viral DNA
Plumer
such that they don't incorporate the
phosphorylated acyclovir okay so two
kinds of resistance mutants one the
phosphorylation doesn't occur in a
second the DNA polymerase doesn't use
the phosphorylated compound now this is
a problem because you may not be able to
treat the infected patient any longer
this is particular problem in AIDS
patients who as you know are
immunocompromised and they can and
herpes infections can be problematic so
if you're treating an AIDS patient with
acyclovir you get resistance you may get
disseminated disease as a consequence
and sometimes you get cross resistance
there are other nucleoside analogs and
you can try them but depending on the
mutation it may be resistant to those as
well there is a different drug entirely
called Foss Garnett which is a DNA
polymerase inhibitor sometimes the
resistant mutants can be inhibited with
that but this has higher side effects
than acyclovir and if you are resistant
to all of these then you have no
treatment options so that's why it's
important to have a big arsenal and in
this case we don't
now acyclovir has been improved over the
years I just want to give you a sense
for the kind of things that have been
done the original drug is acyclovir and
this has been modified chemically by
adding a valine here and I mean of the
amino acid valine
then it's called a Valis cycle of air
and this has improved bioavailability so
this is an orally this can be an orally
taken drug and this one is more
bioavailable after oral administration
what happens here you take it orally and
then cellular enzymes cleave off the
valine right here so that it can be
phosphorylated otherwise it couldn't be
phosphorylated
and then this is the active form so it's
released in you so this is then a pro
drug we call it it's not actually the
active form but has to be modified in
you to become the active drug alright
another one that we'll talk about is
amantadine that was one of the earliest
antiviral drugs discovered this the
target for this drug is the viral m2
which I'm sure you all remember very
well this is an ion channel that is
present in the very odd now you remember
the virion which is shown here at the
left has glycoproteins the hemagglutinin
the purple ones the heat in the
neuraminidase is the orange one and then
there's another membrane protein which
is very low abundance in the virion you
can see it here there's just one of them
shown here that is the m2 protein it
forms an ion channel and just to review
during entry of the virus into cells
that's when that ion channel is
necessary so remember the virus binds a
receptor which has silac acid in it gets
taken up by endocytosis the endosome 's
get acidified protons are pumped into
the endosome that lowers the pH and then
as the pH drops there's a fusion event
that occurs between the viral membrane
and the endosome so that the viral RNA
can then get out and get into the
nucleus so you need low pH now during
this step as these protons go in the
endosome they then get pumped into the
virus through this ion channel this
em--to ion channel and you need to have
reduced pH in the virion itself so that
these RNAs can dissociate and go in the
nucleus so amantadine blocks the
function of this channel so it doesn't
allow protons to go into the interior of
the particle hence when the fusion event
occurs these RNAs remain stuck to the
membrane they don't come off and they
don't go in the nucleus so that's how
you inhibit replication so here is a
model of this the M 2 ion channel is
shown here
it's a tetramer we're showing two chains
here this is the lipid membrane of the
virus so normally protons would be
pumped through here but the amantadine
fits right in the channel it blocks the
protons from being pumped in so that's
why it blocks infectivity because it
blocks entry or encoding of the viral
RNA so in fact by studying amantadine
and amantadine resistance we learned a
lot about uncoding we didn't know that
acidification
Yuriy on was needed for a virus on
coding until we started studying these
amantadine resistant mutants because we
had him Anthony we knew worked we knew a
block the infectivity we didn't know how
and then people got amantadine resistant
mutants they sequenced them and they
said wow this the mutations are in m2
that's unusual so what does m2 doing and
that led to discovering this so really
that's why you studying resistance can
be very important another flu antiviral
is an inhibitor of the neuraminidase so
we haven't talked much about this
protein except to say that it Cleaves
sialic acid from proteins on the cell
surface so let's talk about its function
and when virus is when flu viruses
infect cells remember they are produced
new viruses are produced by budding
alright so viruses are produced by
budding these viruses get glycoproteins
from the plasma membrane DHA in the NA
and then the released particle floats
away from the cell now there's a little
paradox inherent in this and that if you
remember the receptor for these viruses
is silac acid and salic acid is present
on this cell so as these new viruses are
budding off they would just stick to the
surface of the cell if they didn't have
near minute eights there to clear the
sialic acid off of the places where the
viruses are budding so in fact many
years ago we shown that if you block the
function of the viral new many days the
viruses that have produced all cluster
on the cell surface so this was done in
the 1960s and you could see the virus
has never got away and so that led to
the idea of inhibiting the neuraminidase
maybe that would be a good antiviral
approach now many many years later the
structure of the neuraminidase was
solved in conjunction with sialic acids
or the substrate for the nerman days is
sialic acid this is italic acid right
here it fits into a pocket and what the
neuraminidase does is cleave it Cleaves
it off the protein that it's bound to
so the crystallographers looked at this
and they said let's design compounds
that look just like silac acid and make
them bind tightly in the new
many days so that they block its
activity they prevent sialic acid from
getting in and so that's how the two
neuraminidase inhibitors that we use
today Tamiflu and Relenza that's how
they were developed over a 30-year
period so that's they're the two
compounds is in am aveer or Rolen's a--
and also oseltamivir or Tamiflu all
right and these were designed to mimic
sciatic acid which is the ligand of the
inhibitor and the idea was if we make
these look really much like sialic acid
the virus will not be able to mutate to
resistance because then they won't be
able to bind sialic acid and then the
viruses will be dead so this would be a
good strategy okay
so they did that but only one of these
two is a really good mimic of sciatic
acid and that's an AM aveer so Tama vir
is close but not exactly like sciatic
acid so guess which inhibitor you get
resistance to the one that's exactly
like sciatic acid or the one that's not
exactly like you get resistance to
Tamiflu a lot of Tamiflu resistance so
here's a cartoon that illustrates this
so here is neuraminidase on the virion
surface and silac acid on a glycoprotein
on the host cell all right so remember
what's happening is the neuraminidase is
binding the salic acid and it's going to
cleave it off so that the virus
particles can get released from the cell
now also tama viren's anima veer fit
into the pocket that would normally be
occupied by silac acid and as i said i'm
of ear fits really just like sciatic
acid you can see that's we've drawn it
like a triangle here to mimic sciatic
acid but also tama veer is slightly
different it deforms the pocket a little
bit it's not really like silac acid
exactly so you can get mutations in the
neuraminidase that blocked the binding
of Tamiflu but they these viruses are
still viable because they
still by and say alack acid but we
haven't seen many mutations conferring
resistance is in EM aveer some but not
as as much as Tamiflu here's some
numbers for you so there's a really nice
CDC website where you can get weekly
information on influenza virus isolates
in the US and their resistance and so
forth so the top one is a summary of
resistance among influenza viruses
worldwide as of December last year so
these are influenza viruses there are
two subtypes of influenza a circulating
h1n1 and h3n2 you can see both are
resistant to amantadine so those are the
m2 channel inhibitors so Mantha Dean's
pretty useless here amantha Dean's don't
work against influenza B viruses they
don't have an m2 ion channel and so far
all the isolates are susceptible the
majority of isolates are susceptible to
Tamiflu in Zaandam aveer now this is the
new pandemic strain that emerged in 2009
before that virus emerged there was
another h1n1 strain circulating had
almost a hundred percent resistance to
Tamiflu because we'd been using it for
five or six years so over that time we
got all Tamiflu resistant viruses this
is the situation as of October so let's
look at influenza a isolates there are
586 isolates that they tested and they
have one one virus resistant to Tamiflu
so that's not bad but there is one out
there and when there's one there's going
to be more and then we have the pandemic
h1n1 strain 2290 817 which is 0.7% so
slightly higher than the h3n2 so it's
not a lot but the number is growing and
with each successive season the more we
use these inhibitors the more we select
for resistance so eventually where all
the isolates will be resistant to Tammie
fluke most likely I want to go over one
other inhibitor with you and this is an
inhibitor of Pokorny virus on coding
which was discovered in 1985 and I like
the first sentence of this article here
this was done up in
and salir New York many fans of
Rensselaer here know the discovery of
antiviral drugs known today can be
attributed primarily to the tenacity of
researchers and the serendipity of
circumstances this is a good summary of
antiviral discovery back then it's
changed a lot now and it's a lot more
focused but look several years ago a
program was initiated to identify
compounds which demonstrate antiviral
activity against any of a number of RNA
or DNA viruses first compound to show
activity was the dye ketone shown down
here so they had a big chemical
collection they're just screening for
inhibitors they found this one that
worked against a rhinovirus following
this discovery several structural
modifications were made to examine the
following parameters so they made all
these derivatives of the original
compound the chemists went in and added
side chains or rings and so forth and
they simply looked at the minimal
inhibitory concentration in micrograms
per mil and you can see some of them
were not active at all some of them were
more active than others and they
eventually picked the best one and went
forward with it and this was the genesis
of these wind compounds
I've called I think I've told you about
them before these compounds bind into
the capsid of Pokorny viruses in a
hydrophobic pocket just below where the
receptor binds and here is the structure
of one of these wind compounds binding
in this pore it fits tightly in this
pore and prevents the virus for
undergoing conformational changes that
it needs to undergo to unco so this is a
non-coding inhibitor unfortunately this
never made it to be approved because
resistance emerges very readily with the
use of these compounds it was tested for
Rhino virus activity but there's so much
resistance and the Rhino virus holders
are such short duration that it would
had never made it to market but these
are used in the lab to study the process
of uncoding there are many new targets
that are being explored there's for
example the hepatitis C virus protein
shown at the top is a poly protein it's
made as a precursor it's
cleaved by three different kinds of
proteases it has there's a viral serine
protease here there's a viral
metalloproteinase here and then these
cleavages are done by a host signal
protease the host signal peptidase would
that be a good target for developing an
antiviral you think the host signal
peptidase no probably have really bad
side effects because you need that to
cleave signal sequences from proteins
and this one was shown very early on to
be essential if you deleted this
protease from the viral genome it
wouldn't replicate so this is now the
target of antiviral drug discovery for
Hep C on the bottom is another protease
from a different virus this is the
herpes virus cytomegalovirus this is a
very unusual protease structurally it
doesn't seem to be anything like it in
the cell so the idea would be that if
you could find a specific inhibitor it
might not have side-effects but again
you don't know until you put it in into
animals there are clinical trials
ongoing for the Hep C drugs I wanted to
show you you can find these
announcements very easily online at
various websites and these are two
companies starting a phase 2 trial
larger numbers of people answering
different questions of a protease
inhibitor and also there are polymerase
inhibitors for Hep C being developed as
well and these are oral Hep C drugs
there's also mrna antivirals that are
being tested micro rnas are short 22 M
22 nucleotide RNAs that bind target
sequences and cause them to be inhibited
in a variety of ways we've talked about
translational inhibition mediated by
micro RNAs and in this experiment they
took the hepatitis C virus RNA and
designed specific micro rnas to match
sequences in the genome and these
inhibit virus replication so for example
here is a an assay for virus replication
this is a northern blot type of assay
and you can see here the viral RNA is
replicating quite nicely if you add a
micro RNA again
GFP it doesn't affect viral RNA levels
but if you add a virus specific micro
RNA you you block virus replication so
the micro RNA again binds to the viral
genome and inhibits it and these are
being used or being considered for
clinical trial as well because these can
be delivered in a way that makes them
quite stable so micro RNA targets for
some viruses HIV antiviral discovery is
the most extensive of any there are many
targets for intervention of HIV
replication including attachment reverse
transcription integration transcription
and post-transcriptional processing and
assembly and we're going to go through a
couple of these as well
problem with ages that you have years
and years of virus replication remember
10 to the 10th particles a day are
produced and we'll look at the numbers
but that's almost impossible to to get
around the first HIV drug was AZT which
is a thymine derivative and the way it
works is that it's it's phosphorylated
AZT is taken up by the cell it's
phosphorylated by three cellular kinase
a--'s so there's no restriction to virus
infected cells as there is for herpes
simplex virus and then the triphosphate
drug is incorporated into DNA and causes
chain termination because there's no
hydroxyl here there's anna's ido group
it's the the Z and the AZT
so it's chain terminator initially
discovered as an anti tumour compound
actually and then was checked for HIV
inhibition and it worked and as a chain
terminator the reason it is somewhat
specific is that's not a great substrate
for cellular polymerases it's a little
better for the reverse transcriptase so
it's somewhat selective but there are
many many side effects of AZT because it
does inhibit cellular polymerases
so unlike acyclovir has substantial side
effects other problems it's taken orally
it's got good bioavailability it's
absorbed rapidly but the half-life is
horrible an hour so you have to give a
dose as two to three times a day and
this is problematic it makes you feel
lousy it causes anemia
many side effects and this kind of
regimen short half-life with multiple
dosing is a good way to select for virus
mutants and in fact that happened
immediately after the drug was initially
licensed mutants resistant to the drug
arose these contain single amino acid
changes at various places in the reverse
transcriptase so that the drug the
phosphorylated drug would not be
incorporated into the DNA so the altered
enzymes don't bind the phosphorylated
drugs as a result new analogues were
developed chemical modifications of
various sorts or modifications of other
nucleotides and some of those are listed
here and that allowed double combination
therapy to be used the use of two
antivirals at a time nevertheless within
a year even using two drugs resistance
double resistance arose so this led to
the development of non-nucleoside
inhibitors of RT so these are drugs or
compounds that don't mimic nucleosides
but rather they fit into the reverse
transcriptase and they block its
activity so here's the structure of
reverse transcriptase the polymerase
active site is right here and these
non-nucleoside inhibitors bind a short
distance from the active site so they
probably perturb the active site enough
so that it doesn't work and inhibits the
enzyme and there a couple of these that
are being used at the moment now also
you get resistance to these of course
very rapidly
you know acid substitutions in the
enzyme that prevent the drug from
binding or modify the structure of the
enzyme even when the drug is present so
you can't use these by themselves and
they're typically used in combination
therapy now when you get when you have
so many drugs that are available you can
then see if resistance to one drug does
something with respect to resistance to
another and you want to know this
because you have a patient that becomes
resistant to one drug you don't want to
give them another drug to which they're
already resistant so you need to know
their resistance profiles and some
surprising results have been have
emerged and these are all examples of
where resistance to one drug actually
restore
susceptibility to another so here we
have for example a change which confers
resistance to this inhibitor and that if
you put them on a second drug died an
Essene and you get resistance to that it
restores susceptibility to the original
drug so this is this is the case for all
of these compounds if the resistance to
a second compound restore susceptibility
yeah well in heart there are only six
combinations that are approved and some
and these are some of the considerations
that are part of that yeah you want to
make sure that you're not going to get
if resistant to one doesn't give you
resistance to all three but also some of
these considerations come into play as
well so actually you don't make up your
own combinations you have to use
pre-approved ones and those issues have
come into play in fact nowadays if you
are diagnosed with AIDS you have to the
you have to have a resistance profile
done best way is to sequence the genome
in all the areas of known resistance and
see what mutations you have and then
pick the treatment based on the sequence
and obviously the more sensitive the
sequencing the better off you are
because there can be very small variants
present which might not be detected
unless you're doing very sensitive
sequencing there are a number of anti-v
anti-hiv drugs that target the protease
remember the virus matures by assembly
of a poly protein that's processed by
viral protease and the virus buds at the
surface one of these proteins is the
protease PR the yellow circle here it's
incorporated into the particle and
processes that poly protein as the
particle matures and very early on it
was shown that this protease was
essential so it was used to develop
antiviral drugs a key discovery was that
it would recognize small peptides he
didn't need a whole protein substrate to
be recognized but you could have a small
peptide and that the active site of the
protease contains seven amino acids of
the substrate so that was
also useful so initially a number of
inhibitors protease inhibitors that had
already been investigated in
hypertension studies provided the first
leads for this work
these protease inhibitors actually
inhibited the HIV protease these are
peptidyl mimics they mimic the natural
cleavage site so these were the first
drugs and then subsequently
mechanism-based screens and and other
structure based designs were used to
discover more so here is the sequence of
the protease substrate these are the
amino acids that comprise one cleavage
site in one of the viral proteins and
this is the recognition sequence here
and then this inhibitor on the bottom
mimics this protease cleavage site you
can see here and then it's different on
either side so this might this binds
very tightly to the protease it's a
peptide oh man medic it mimics the
substrate and inhibits its activity so
now we use combination therapy triple
therapy because the resistance the
probability of resistance is it just the
product of the individual resistances so
if you have two drugs with probabilities
of resistance one in ten to the three
one in ten to the four you need to have
ten to the seventh variants to get
resistance which is not a lot
considering you get ten to the seventh
ten to the tenth particles made a day
and typically you target different
mechanisms in this cocktail and as we've
said before that way you can treat the
infection as a chronic disease and very
recently one pill was approved that has
all three inhibitors in it which makes
it much easier than having to remember
all the combinations on a daily basis
so here the mathematics of drug
resistance which you're worth going
through if you assume that one mutation
is needed for drug resistance which
sometimes is true but not always and if
the virus mutates one in every ten to
the four bases which is once per genome
per cycle then in every 10,000 viruses
every base is substituted so any pool of
10,000 viruses that you put out has a
chain and each virus does a change at a
different position in theory so you make
10 to the 10th new viruses a day
so that means 10 to the 6 viruses are
produced each day with resistance to one
drug a million that's why one drug
doesn't work very well now if you take
two drugs
10 to the 8th viruses and it's divided
10 to the 10th over 10 to the 8th a
hundred viruses are made each day that
are resistant to both drugs so that's a
little better but eventually you will
get resistance in about a year and then
if you do three drugs the rate is 10 to
the 12th so you need fewer viruses but
eventually you will get there as well
depending on how much your the growth is
going on remember replication is
suppressed so the the number of 10 to
the 10th particles a day is going to be
brought down significantly by triple
therapy so it will take much much longer
to get resistance my understanding is
that you do get resistance but they are
mostly a consequence of people stopping
their therapy for whatever reason and
the virus grows and the resistant
mutants grow back some new antivirals
have been developed recently one of them
is the integrase inhibitor that we have
mentioned a couple of times in this
course remember the viral DNA integrates
into the hosts DNA and this integrates
protein mediates the strand invasion by
the viral DNA the integrase inhibitors
simply bind the integrase and prevent
this joining this nicking and joining
reaction and this is an example of one
of the integrase inhibitors you can see
it's a small molecule that forms a
variety of interactions with specific
amino acids of the integrase now of
course you can get resistance to these
as well and those those have been well
described in the literature you can see
here integrase inhibitor resistance
mutations there are two different
integrase inhibitors shown at the bottom
here and all the different amino acid
changes that you can get to give
resistance I thought I would show you
this study which is one way that you
test an antiviral drug in a clinical
trial so this is a double blinded
randomized placebo-controlled trial a
dose ranging study
different doses to find out which one is
good and they put 200 400 and 600
milligrams of rel tag Revere and of
course the placebo and these are blinded
so nobody knows who's getting what and
then they measure the viral RNA either a
change in baseline or the proportion of
patients with RNAs of different copies
per mil less than 400 or less than 50 so
this is the gold standard getting less
than 50 copies per mil and then the
change in the cd4 cell count so you can
see these are the numbers for the
placebos and if you compare the drug
treatment take the highest amount of
drugs 600 milligrams you can see that
this is a a big change a negative change
in the baseline of RNAi compared to the
placebo proportion of patients with less
than 50 copies per mil 66 percent
compared to 13% so you can see this is
quite effective slightly more effective
than 400 milligrams per mil 400
milligrams this is an inhibitor of ccr5
which we talked about a long time ago
ccr5 is the co receptor remember that is
needed for HIV infection it's a small
molecule that binds in ccr5 and causes a
change in the molecule such that the
virus doesn't undergo high affinity
binding but of course you get resistance
to that as well and finally there are
fusion inhibitors these are actually
peptides 36 amino acid peptides which
interfere with the fusion reaction so
normally when fusion occurs here's the
viral membrane and here's the host cell
target gp120 or the envelope protein
binds the receptor on the host cell the
fusion protein is exposed inserts into
the cell membrane and then remember
there's a conformational change in this
protein that hairpins draws the two
membranes together so that they can fuse
we looked at movies of this a long time
ago these peptides what they do is they
bind these alpha helixes that have
extended here in the glycoprotein so
these small cylinders are the peptides
the anti
our peptides that are binding and they
lock it into this position so it can't
undergo the hair pinning and the fusion
so these block fusion these are very
expensive drugs and they have to be
reconstituted just before injection so
you get them as a dry powder you add
buffer to them and you inject them and
it's very expensive and of course we get
resistance by amino acid changes along
these alpha helixes that simply prevent
the binding of the peptide and some of
these are just examples of the kinds of
mutations that you get these have been
well studies changes in gp41 which is
the subunit of the glycoprotein to which
these peptides bind and these are all
tracked that I website the HIV DB where
you can look at all the resistance
mutations in real time so this is the
chart of all the available HIV
antivirals at the moment they're
classified according to the mechanism so
you can see nucleoside RT inhibitors
non-nucleoside inhibitors protease
inhibitors then we have our fusion
inhibitor we just talked about the ccr5
inhibitor integrase inhibitor and then
various combination products so this is
the triple a-- a triple a-- which is the
pill that contains three different drugs
and then other combinations can be given
separately what's interesting about this
table is that you can see they're very
very rapid approval rate for most of
these drugs usually takes much much
longer to have drugs approved so this is
the time to approval where you submit
your data to the FDA and they say it's
okay and this of course being an urgent
situation they're all fast-tracked and
given fast-track type approval so some
of them are just a few months to
approval which is amazing so you see we
have a big arsenal and that allows it to
be effectively treated yes
is it sorry for drugs yeah okay and what
would be the resistance to for drugs B
would be very high but eventually you'd
probably get there but remember this is
why a lot of genomes on the planet and
no matter what you make you're gonna get
resistance